louisiana televangelist is asking his
followers for donations to buy a 54
million dollar private jet
jesse duplantis runs a church outside
new orleans and also
reaches out that also reaches out
worldwide more than 750 000 people watch
his sermons online
and follow his ministry's facebook page
he is the second
prominent televangelist this year to
preach the virtues of a private plane
tony de copo is here with why duplantis
insists
he needs the jet tony good morning good
morning it's a good question because the
ministry already has a jet
okay they've had three in fact but
duplanta says he needs this new one to
be able to go anywhere around the world
in a single stop
in order to spread the gospel to as many
people as possible
we want that 7x we're believing god for
it in a video posted to his website last
week
televangelist jesse duplantis says god
told him he needs the new falcon 7x jet
that if jesus was physically on the
earth today he wouldn't be riding a
donkey
think about that for a minute he'd be in
an airplane preaching the gospel all
over the world
reaction to this multi-million dollar
request has been mixed on the ministry's
facebook page
one person wrote i am ashamed i ever
listened to a word you had to say
another posted i believe pastor jesse
will have his plane
and that is the way god has planned it
duplentis is not the first minister to
preach the gospel of private flying
if i want to believe god for a 65
million dollar plane
you cannot stop me in 2015 creflo dollar
asked his suburban atlanta congregation
for a new
gulfstream g650 his ministry settled for
a used one
father we thank you and this past
january texas based televangelist
kenneth copeland announced the blessing
of a new multi-million dollar gulfstream
five
copeland and duplantis both defended
using private jets in 2015.
the world is in such a shape we can't
get there without this
sunday morning i was in boston
massachusetts monday i was in new
orleans
tuesday i was in chicago the lord says
how we treat the poor
is how we're going to be judged jim
wallace is the founder of sojourners a
prominent christian community
stories of pastors and private jets
are not the best way of exemplifying
what we mean by following jesus
we don't know how much jesse duplantis
ministry has raised so far
and we are unable to reach him or anyone
at his ministry for comment
de plantes says that the three planes
they've owned have been purchased
in cash and he hopes to do the same with
this one if you're going to buy a
private plan of in cash purchases is the
way to go
well of course is there any other way
tony to cope i applaud you for doing
that story with a straight face
did i i don't think i did because it's
not like the minister said i would like
one or could you help me out but he said
i need one
he acknowledges some people don't
believe preachers should have a private
jet but he believes in using all outlets
all right well jesus jesus said to his
disciples don't even take a second tunic
so he didn't even get to private plans
we'll see how this turns out